the nominees for Best Supporting Actor
this year are as varied and exceptional
as the films in which they were featured
and the nominees ranged from a 19 year
old young man making his feature film
debut to a two-time Academy Award winner
in this category and in between there
are three actors of experience who bring
a rise in stature to any part they play
and all five nominees have one thing in
common they are outstanding
practitioners of the art of acting the
nominees are Judd Hirsch in ordinary
people
Timothy Hutton in ordinary people
Michael of Peace in the Great Santini
Joe Pesci and Raging Bull
envelope honors Ogata gabbatha and Jason
Robards aha
in Melvin
could be overlooked Jason Robards
there's no way ever all right open that
okay yeah please may I
you're gonna make me open it yeah you do
it the winner is
Timothy Hutton
thank you all very much um is the first
award and I'm very nervous about what to
say here I'd like to thank everybody
involved with ordinary people the cast
Mary thank you Judd Thank You Donald
Thank You Liz McGovern thank you
and I'd like to thank Judith guests and
I'd like to thank Alvin Sargent and Jeff
canoe but most of all I'd really like to
thank our wonderful director Robert
Redford
I love you and finally I'd like to thank
my father I wish he was here
thank you all very much
you